aujourd'hui l'assemblée nationale a
adopté à l'unanimité une motion soutient
nathalie morin son nom vous dit
peut-être quelque chose c'est cette
québécoise de 35 ans maintenant coincé
en arabie saoudite depuis treize ans
avec ses quatre enfants
malgré la médiatisation périodique de
son histoire
rien n'avance revoyons quelques dates
importantes de cette affaire en 2001 at
elle y rencontre son conjoint saïd
al-chahrani à montréal en 2005 elle
déménagea d'arabie saoudite avec son
mari dont elle est follement amoureuse
et son premier enfant samir autant 2006
elle passe deux mois au québec puis
retourne en arabie saoudite où elle est
coincée depuis ce temps et en 2013 les
saoudiens accepte que nathalie aille au
québec avec les enfants à condition de
canada garantissent le retour de la
famille en arabie saoudite que le canada
a refusé 2016 deux ans près de
l'ambassade du canada rencontre nathalie
morin aucun résultat la journaliste
michèle ouimet de la presse l'a
rencontrée en 2018 ya un très bon papier
là dessus d'ailleurs dans la presse j'ai
joué j'ai sa mère à mes côtés même
obtenu une motion à l'assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui où en est la
sphère quelles sont les nouvelles dans
la nouvelle que vous avez les seules
nouvelles que j'ai donné thalys etc à
peux pas me parler ce que qu'en cas
m'envoie des textos très causé pour me
dire qu'à cause de la situation allait
pas droit de parler je la sens terrorisé
je sens qu'à la part des déportés
déportation ses enfants oui sans ses
enfants c'est ce qui avait pas de
déportés sans ses enfants
est-ce que moi selon moi c'est son
conjoint qui a manipulé avec ça parce
qu'à part djamel web masarotti est ce
que c'est vrai qu'à des portraits au pot
je ne peux pas savoir le boisement
canadien avec qui
moi je suis en contact ici il
il avance qu'il y avait des problèmes
avec nathalie contacter quelqu'un des
contacts saoudien qui eux pouvaient
contrôler les conjoints de ma fille mais
maintenant depuis un angle vaguement
canadien aux sports contactés les
saoudiens dont il y aurait un espace
pour rejoindre l'italie a envoyé une
lettre par courrier des jeunes par
courrier recommandé
rien qui parle cia répond pas apporté
soit pas le courrier avant quand jean
pierre masson sur son sillage déchéance
de son cellulaire
ça sonnait sans réponse mais maintenant
le téléphone est coupé way opel était
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
quand même intéressant de savoir qu'elle
avait des amis sur facebook et autres
réseaux sociaux
y a pas personne que de nouvelles d al
almi 1 pouces le 17 octobre
je pense que le 17 octobre et est écrit
à deux trois amis ça je peux pas être
sûr à 100% lotis je dois inquiète pour
elle en ce moment oui je suis inquiet je
suis inquiète parce que si le balma
canadien ça n'occupe pas ça veut dire
qu'elle elle est complètement sous
l'emprise de son conjoint qui j'étais
ravie de charité ma fille il travaille
même pour lui si ce n'est pas quelqu'un
de recommandant plus envie que tu as
fait soit seul avec lui lieu des
allégations de violence conjugale
oui beaucoup il ya toujours été violent
il était violent aussi avec les
enfermant ce que sa mère a remis une
lettre au gouvernement canadien qui est
allé à la halle des gens de l'ambassade
porter l'habit cité pourrait expliquer
comment sont pas et s'ils prenaient pour
le bac lui parce qu'ils sont pas payés
l'étrangler puis avait une plainte à
l'école là les colts en était rendu
complet va contacter le
le gouvernement canadien et c'est à dire
qu'ils ont contacté aussi ça me dépasse
je regarde les images on s'est fait
tellement longtemps j'ai pas du mois dès
lors je sais ça mais aussi est battu
probablement les autres j'ai pas de
nouvelles dernièrement fait que je peux
pas le dire avec certitude ça mais c'est
certain et aussi ce qui est important de
réaliser c'est que le gouvernement
canadien ont accueilli des jeunes faij
saoudien des jeunes paie d'ailleurs
parce que bon à cause des violences qui
vivent à l'extérieur puis j'ai pris
vraiment j'ai pu sortir mais moi j'ai ma
fille qui est victime de violence j'ai
ma petite et ça rend
c'est une fée dans le disent en avoir
bientôt 11 ans sont par pile avant mon
mariage je n'ai porté qui on peut rien
faire
et puis là le canada toujours invoquer
le fait qu' ils sont mariés et que donc
elle est soumise jamais mariés
non non il y en a ils se sont jamais
mariés
lui avait dit que c'était mario canada
donc les saoudiens ont émis un papy pour
dire qu'ils y approuvé le mariage qui
avait lieu au canada mais jamais de
mariage au canada le lendemain canadien
quand j'ai débuté elle ne m'aime pas
jamais marié on se pince lyssoises elle
a constamment y est on là qu'on s'est
pas marié mais à ce moment qu'un jet à
selle ils font rien ils font vraiment
rien pour nathalie en ce moment j'ai
demandé à plusieurs reprises de
rencontrer notre premier ministre
monsieur trudeau la menace pauline et
moi je voudrais les rencontrer pour
expliquer pourquoi m'expliquer peut-être
que je suis las palmas même vont
comprendre que ça va prendre une volonté
politique pour sortir et aller je suis
convaincu que si notre premier ministre
d'eau appelé le roi abdallah ou mbs
sa valeur est de l'appeler comme ça un
bf je suis certaine qu'ils seraient
capables de négocier parce que ça y est
de toujours travailler pour son
gouvernement il était protégé par son
gouvernement
c'est sûr que c'est par là que ça va
passer quand même qu'un fonctionnaire
rappellerait look on essaye n'importe
quoi ça marchera pour tient aussi une
autre chose que j'ai demandée vers la
caméra j'ai pas de réponse encore ça
fait plusieurs années que je demande un
moment donné j'avais réussi à obtenir un
visa temporaire pour sailly que ça mène
ici avec entrées multiples et là on
n'était pas capable de voir les visas de
sortie pour les enfants
et selon lui il ya eu une réunion avec
l'ambassade canadienne nathalie et sayid
le 27 novembre 2013 et le gouvernement
saoudien al zaïm
si tu veux qu'on autorise les enfants
sortir du pays
tu dois renoncer à sa paternité lui
était pas prêt à faire ça mais ce que
ces breaks le gouvernement forte demande
si c'est lui qui nous dit ça moi je
demande aux commandes mcaleese et
j'aimerais avoir l'information est ce
que je dois me battre avec le vent glacé
audio avec le conjoint est ce que vous y
verrez consulaires n'ont plus régulière
il ya eu un décès consulaire
le 6 mars 2018 giuseppe base il est allé
lui rendre visite
y est allé lui rendre visite le jour
pendant que les enfants à l'école
pourtant ici que samir était battu et y
est revenue en me disant mais madame du
registre parce que nathalie m'a prodigué
l'apprenons canada mais soyons jeudi
parce qu'on le sait tout le monde le
sait l'op
oui mais dit pas laquelle ledit cette
journée là mais parce qu'elle savait pas
si on ne savait pas autres et c'est tout
de suite après que michel baumettes fait
l'article dans la presse papier vais
revenir
ben ouais pas voudrais vous écrivez moi
après ça j'ai envoyé peut-être une
quinzaine de courriers qui n'était la
demande est rapatrié très bien alors
donc souhaiter bon courage encore une
fois ce n'est pas la première fois que
je vous rends compte au fil des années
c'est commence à faire sa 13 ans oui
alors merci beaucoup merci on change